una estrategia para mitigar la sequía el
gobernador de california busca
solucionar los graves problemas de agua
que sufre el estado en los últimos años
la hidrología en el estado ha comenzado
a cambiar de forma bastante
significativa la aridificación que
estamos experimentando nos lleva la
ciencia y los datos nos llevan a
entender ahora que perderemos el 10 por
ciento de nuestro suministro de agua
para 2040
para reducir esta cifra anunció que la
planta desalinizadora que se está
construyendo en antioch una población a
72 kilómetros de san francisco
convertirá el agua salobre en agua
potable además el plan prevé la creación
del almacenamiento de casi 5 mil
millones de metros cúbicos de agua el
reciclaje o reutilización del líquido y
proyectos de captación de aguas
pluviales
la realidad es que tenemos que ser más
creativos y tenemos que ser más
agresivos en términos no sólo de
promover esta tecnología sino de cumplir
con su promesa es más cumplir con su
potencial de chacho el estado reservo
más de 8 mil millones de dólares en los
últimos tres años para modernizar las
infraestructuras hídricas
en agua suficiente para 84 millones de
hogares en un estado de 40 millones de
habitantes la crisis del agua se ha
visto agravada por el cambio climático
california y el oeste del país han
experimentado una sequía extrema en los
últimos 20 años algunos científicos han
medido este periodo como el más seco en
1200 años este fenómeno ha ocasionado
fuertes incendios como el de mckinney
que dejó más de 22 mil hectáreas de
bosque calcinado y cientos de afectados